[Music]
all across the earth
the history of life and of the planet
itself
is written in its rocks
[Music]
fossils large and small are embedded in
rocks layered on top of each other
and by traversing these layers now
exposed at the surface
paleontologists can take a trip through
time traveling back about 66 million
years
rock layers all over the world preserve
a remarkable transition from a world
ruled by
giants to one reeling from their sudden
absence
rock layers older than 66 million years
belong to the cretaceous period
the third and final age of dinosaurs
improbably huge fossils are the remains
of improbably
gigantic creatures that roamed the land
surface and ocean depths
grazing hunting living every conceivable
lifestyle
on this ancient earth but
the rocks younger than 66 million years
tell a very different story here
at the beginning of the paleogene the
fossils are vastly diminished
both in number and in size they tell of
a world
devoid of dinosaurs stripped of its
giants
entirely no four-legged animal weighing
more than 25 kilos lives in this new
world
they are mostly small among which are
our own ancestors
and it is a quiet empty world in which
just
25 of cretaceous species
remain this is the cretaceous paleogene
boundary
a line frozen between worlds
an armageddon marked in stone
unimaginably
catastrophic
first posited by father and son team
walter and luis alvarez in 1980
the alvarez hypothesis is a symbol of
how brutal life on our planet can be
in 1979 with hammer and chisel they had
extracted and examined a sample of the
cretaceous paleogene border
in the italian aponines half of the
fist-sized rock belonging to the age of
the dinosaurs
and the other to a world of small
mammals
through the middle of it a fine dark
wavering line was the only remnant of a
catastrophic event
that had ended the dinosaur's reign
in that delicate layer walter and lewis
discovered inflated concentrations of
iridium
a metal that's extremely rare on earth
but which
they theorized was delivered by an
asteroid
66 million years ago an 80 kilometer
wide asteroid
smashed into the yucatan peninsula in
mexico
obliterating itself in the process and
spreading iridium
in a fine layer over the entire globe it
triggered a string of catastrophic
climatic and tectonic changes that in a
mere
30 000 years decimated life on earth
dinosaurs died never to return
along with 75 of all species
on the planet the living world was
utterly
transformed and yet this brutal impact
and its subsequent horrors
were nowhere near the worst mass
extinction event
the earth had seen
[Music]
nearly 200 million years deeper in time
at the end of the permian period
earth's biodiversity plummeted in a
geological blink of the eye
this time there was no external agent of
destruction
the earth itself conspired to call forth
its armageddon
huge volcanic eruptions spewed lava dust
clouds and gases
transforming the planet the changes
drove ancient species from many
different families to extinction
including trilobites ammonites and some
of the earliest
land-dwelling mammals and reptiles 96
of all marine species and 70 percent of
terrestrial vertebrates
were lost known colloquially
as the great dying this has been widely
held as the most deadly
of earth's many extinction events
but there is one more candidate
for this grisly crown billions of
years deeper in time
the evidence may not be as clear as the
boundary rock walter alvarez held in his
hand
but much much closer to the formation of
our world
there is record of an event so
catastrophic
that it almost saw the loss of all
life on earth
[Music]
in the archaean world at least two and a
half billion years ago
the microbial ecosystem thrives in
blissful ignorance
of the coming apocalypse life is limited
to diverse bacteria clusters around
hydrothermal vents
peppering the ocean floor feeding off
the various minerals disgorged from
these
smoking chimneys but these are crowded
microcosms
these microbes can only stray so far
from the life-giving chemistry
on which their metabolisms rely and the
hydrothermal chimneys
can only supply so much so
new metabolisms emerge through mutations
of the genetic molecule
the bacteria learn to do new things with
the chemicals they're surrounded with
not only that but they can exchange
their newfound skills with their sisters
in a genetic handshake of which only
these simple life forms are capable
bumping against each other gently in the
crowded vent metropolis
two microbes can briefly link their
membranes
and shuttle tiny packets of genetic
material
back and forth constantly trading genes
and creating new combinations within
their own cells
this was the source of staggering
diversity in these gloomy seas
and the mechanism that birthed an
entirely new innovation
one that was to ultimately transform the
face of the planet
[Music]
that innovation was of pigments
tiny specks that would appear purple to
our eyes but which are capable of
absorbing specific wavelengths of light
and capturing the energy suddenly
microbial life forms have a brand new
source of energy available to them
the light from the sun sunlight is
inexhaustible and
easily accessible as long as you can
survive the waves and tides that haunt
the shallows
to the first light-loving microbes in a
chemical world their innovation opened
the doors to a brand new kind of
existence
these photo troughs could eat
the sun this
was the birth of photosynthesis but it
wasn't the photosynthesis we learn about
in school
it was a strange noxious kind of
chemistry with exotic ingredients
purple colored bacteria fed on the sun's
infrared light
beyond the visible spectrum they used
hydrogen and dissolved sulfides to
complete their reactions and produced
solid yellow sulfur and corrosive
sulfuric acid
as by-products the early photosynthetic
world
was a toxic stinking mire
but this wasn't the cause of the
catastrophe to come
even after bacteria learned to eat the
sun innovation continued
through the microbial gene exchange and
much trial and error
iterative improvements were made to the
new metabolism
new green pigments absorb red and blue
light
capturing more energy than ever before
and a new
simpler kind of chemistry is developed
one that relies not on noxious sulfur
but on ubiquitous
water in this new and improved form of
photosynthesis
the sun's energy is combined with carbon
dioxide and water
to power cells metabolism this
is the successful pathway that has been
handed down
through billions of years and upon which
green plants and algae rely to this day
but this wildly successful new pathway
had a dark side
it created a waste product more deadly
and noxious than any sulfur that came
before
a toxic waste product that would bring
disaster
even to the organisms that made it and
one
we are still living with today
oxygen
[Music]
oxygen may not seem so terrible to us
indeed
we can scarcely imagine a world without
it every animal on earth today relies on
oxygen
for its own metabolism but in the late
archaean and early proterozoic
two and a half billion years ago it was
a novelty
to which the entire planet was
unaccustomed
[Music]
in september 1844 the southern shores of
lake superior
were a wilderness of hardy white pines
casting
long shadows over a softly undulating
landscape
of ice-smoothed rock a small team of
prospectors are working their way
through this landscape
led by one william burt
he is a geologist and surveyor sent to
the northern peninsula of michigan
to seek out new metal oars michigan
already has a thriving copper industry
and investors seek to exploit ever more
of the state's
natural bounty so late one september
afternoon
as the sun casts a golden glow over the
landscape
william burt squints and peers at his
compass
something isn't right the sun in his
eyes
tells him he's facing west but the
compass needle points
straight ahead he turns to the north to
look across the glittering waters of the
lake
but the needle still points resolutely
into
the hillside
at bert's instruction the surveyors set
up camp here
and begin their investigations to
discover the cause
of the compass's strange behavior
several days of digging hacking and
blasting later the prospectors stand
before
a clean unweathered rock surface
the likes of which a small team has
never seen
the rocks are vivid red and jet black
strikingly arranged in smoothly
alternating layers
some mere millimeters thick others half
as tall
as a man later testing will reveal that
iron makes up more than thirty percent
of these rocks
compared to just five percent on average
in the earth's crust
with little more than a compass needle
william burt
had struck michigan's black stony gold
these iron rich rocks would come to be
known as banded iron formations
and they would bring michigan steaming
into the industrial revolution
[Music]
but banded iron formations have more to
offer than just their mineral resources
these rocks now exploited in northern
michigan were birthed in the proterozoic
oceans
2.4 billion years ago
they are the lucrative product of a
world in crisis
with the invention of water-based
photosynthesis oxygen was being produced
and emitted into the oceans for the
first time
in earth's history oxygen is a
remarkably reactive element
and will instantly combine with almost
any other element creating brand
new compounds in the proterozoic oceans
the newly created oxygen reacts with the
green iron hydroxide suspended through
the water column
transforming it into iron oxide
rust
spreading out from the shores where the
photosynthetic bacteria thrive
the waters turn an apocalyptic blood red
over time the iron oxide settles
floating down
through miles of water to be deposited
on the ocean floor
they become the crimson iron-rich layers
in the banded iron formations
but a curious thing is happening in the
shallows
while the first innovative microbes may
have evolved to use the efficient new
form of photosynthesis
they haven't yet evolved a resistance to
oxygen
without protection the waste product
builds up in their cells
reacting aggressively with the delicate
chemical machinery that keeps them alive
the microbes have no protection because
they've never needed it
until now
so these new bacteria are suffocated by
their own
waste gases dying in droves just as they
reach the peak of their success
when populations grow too large the flow
of oxygen in the ocean exceeds what can
be removed by iron
and the entire shallows are oxygenated
the toxic oxygen sweeps like poison gas
over the bacterial communities lying
prostrate in the sun
killing them where they lie with the
sun-loving microbes slaughtered
oxygen production all but stops and
normal service resumes in the ocean
depths
muddy shales and silica rich cherts
accumulate
free of iron oxide covering the red
sediments
but the oxygenic cleansing isn't
absolute
not all photosynthetic bacteria are
wiped out
life finds a way
microbes find their way back to the
dappled coastal waters
their populations bounce back and they
begin to pour oxygen
back into the ocean once again
and so the cycle repeats
millions of years of blooming and dying
of oxygen levels rising and falling of
red iron oxides alternating with black
anoxic
silicates gradually pulse by pulse the
banded iron formations accumulate
they are an elegant deep sea record
of a bitter battle for survival in the
shallows
[Music]
banded iron formations like the ones
discovered by william burt in michigan
are found today on almost
every continent they formed across huge
swathes of the deep proterozoic ocean
and record pulsing oxygen levels lasting
200
million years but
this is just the beginning of the oxygen
catastrophe
to come
geologists examining the rocks of the
earliest proterozoic
notice a striking transition around 2.4
billion years ago
the black basild and its black sands and
black muddy riverbeds
for the first time turn red
the phenomenon is more widespread than
just the deep sea banded iron formations
this is a transformation that took over
the entire globe around 2.4 billion
years ago
the earth rusted
but how did this happen how did the
photosynthetic micro cosmos
break out of its seemingly endless boom
and bust
cycle
with enough time the photosynthesizers
have chance to innovate
exchange and evolve eventually they
evolved to withstand their own waste
gases
oxygen no longer poisoned them straight
away they could live long enough to grow
their numbers
bolster their population and maintain
their tenuous grip on the sun-lit
shallows without periodic devastation
they could soak up the sun
and belch out oxygen uninhibited
before long the seas ran out of iron to
soak up the excess oxygen
bringing about the end of widespread
banded iron formations
oxygen begins to fill the oceans
dissolved in the water beginning
at the shore and spreading inexorably
into the darkest depths
ocean currents bring tons of oxygenated
water
into the furthest reaches of the
proterozoic oceans
oxygen silent deadly spread
is catastrophic for the rest of the
biosphere
those crowded microbial communities
clinging to hydrothermal chimneys in the
dark
never change their ways they never
exchange their genes with sun lovers
and they have no resistance to toxic
oxygen
they are decimated
even those that survive the initial cull
are deprived of the chemicals on which
they depend
oxygen reacts with iron sulfur and
manganese emitted from the vent
oxidizing it and locking it away in
deposits
now inaccessible to these primitive
microbes
as oxygen spreads through the ocean so
microbial city
after city fall gassed
poisoned starved and rusted to death
there was no escape the
photosynthesizers had brought about a
new world order in which there was only
room for those tolerant
to their regime but even this
was not the end
the thin layer of iridium that walter
alvarez and his father discovered in
italy in 1980 was a record of the
asteroid that started the kt
extinction the impact obliterated
everything for miles around
sent shockwaves around the globe started
forest fires and
filled the skies with smoke but
for the majority of the biosphere death
came much slower during a global
winter that gripped the planet for years
after
or during intense warming that followed
it was the climatic after effects that
dealt the final blow
so too with the great proterozoic
extinction
[Music]
in 1868 just over the canadian border
from the then
thriving iron mines in northern michigan
exploring geologists discover another
curious rock formation on the shores of
lake huron
here they uncover a strange amalgam of
pebbles and boulders
set in a fine gray cement-like matrix
from tiny gritty grains to boulders
weighing several tons
the stones are a colorful assortment of
many different rock types
speckled white and gray granites striped
orange jaspers and greenstone
glinting in the sun
there are no matching source rocks for
these exotic pieces
for hundreds even thousands of miles the
largest boulders are too heavy
to be moved by wind or water to the 19th
century geologists
their presence here is a mystery it is
as if
they have been dropped from the sky
today we know many more examples of
these mysterious
exotic rocks from later periods of
earth's history
they are called erratics and they are
indeed dropped
although not from the sky rather
from melting glaciers pebbles and
boulders are plucked from the bedrock
and transported along vast icy highways
before being deposited
unceremoniously when that ice melts away
only the unstoppable progress of ice has
the power to move
so much rock so far from its source
the erratics around lake huron are
exceptional in both their age
and their variety dating to at least 2.1
billion years ago
they are the remnants of not just one
glacier but a vast
ice field transporting debris across
thousands of miles the so-called
huronian glaciation named for these
deposits
was an ice age like no other it was the
ice catastrophe
that followed the oxygen catastrophe
and the nail in the coffin for much of
life
on earth
the seas filled with oxygen and wiped
out the deep sea microbial communities
but the photosynthetic communities
continued to thrive pumping out more and
more oxygen until the seas could hold no
more
so the waste oxygen began to eek into
the atmosphere
here it reacted with exposed rocks but
it also reacted with other gases in the
air
most notably it tore apart molecules of
methane
transforming them into carbon dioxide
and while we know carbon dioxide today
to be a warming greenhouse gas
on the early earth methane was a much
more potent insulator
as the skies were stripped of their
downy methane blanket
global temperatures dropped the greedy
surviving photosynthesizers continued to
gobble at the carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere
depleting the planet's insulation even
more
the earth was then plunged into an ice
age
of unimaginable proportions the sun
shone less brightly than today and with
the planet losing what little heat it
once retained
the lakes rivers and oceans began to
freeze
ice shelves edged towards the equator
spreading like
freezing corruption from the shallows
over the deep oceans
before long the earth was a snowball
planet
head to toe in a cloak of featureless
ice
and so it remained for 300 million years
with every continental shelf frozen
solid covered by ice a hundred meters
thick
even the voracious photosynthesizers met
their match
the shallow sea floor froze solid
entombing microbial communities in solid
ice
deeper water that escaped the freeze was
black as night below the thick
opaque ice for microbes that eat the sun
this endless night was an inescapable
death sentence
after reaping devastation on the archaic
life forms in the deep ocean
they are eventually the very agents of
their own destruction
together the chemical revolution and the
ensuing climate crisis combined to bring
about the biggest
mass extinction that the earth has ever
seen
it's often overlooked in the face of
more recent extinctions where staggering
numbers of species are lost
or huge charismatic animals like the
dinosaurs disappear forever
but the great oxygen extinction saw
primary productivity the production of
organic compounds by life
plummet scientists estimate that 99
of all life on earth was lost between
2.4
and 2 billion years ago the bountiful
microbial oceans of the archaean were
wiped out
forever and the majority of those ocean
ecosystems would never recover
just one percent of life clung on
through the toxic ice age
deep ocean refuge untouched by the
poison gas
or in rare warm coastline oases that
somehow escaped
the global freeze all life on earth
today
is descended from those lucky few who
made it
against the odds oxygenic
photosynthesis a chemical innovation
made by tiny bacteria nearly two and a
half billion years ago
is the fundamental root of most of our
modern ecosystems
and yet its invention almost brought
about the destruction
of all life on earth
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth
like and subscribe and leave a comment
to tell us what you think
and we'll see you next time